six barrels means six times the action
whenever a game or movie needs to dial
up the action another notch the raw of
the brass spewing minigun is there
whether it's mounted to a helicopter or
fired by a t-800 terminator
mini by name but not by nature the
minigun is a must-have for any action
movie blockbuster set piece or for a
larger-than-life action hero
but the minigun actually owes its
creation to a man who thought he could
put an end to wars entirely so why is it
then with its colossal reputation and a
history spanning centuries do movies and
video games keep getting the spinning
more of the minigun so wrong i'm here at
the royal armouries museum in the uk to
unravel its legacy
[Music]
so what exactly is a minigun and how did
something that's pretty far from
miniature and such a peculiar name well
commonly in pop culture the word is used
as a rather generic term to describe any
number of spinning multi-borrowed
machine guns the gun on the back of a
halo warthog minigun one of the heavy
weapons carried by fallout's brotherhood
of steel minigun the spinning barrelled
46 from wolfenstein the new order sure
as heck looks like a minigun huh even
when games change up the name the term
mini gun still fits in the mind of the
player in reality however the term
actually refers to a specific weapon the
m134 minigun many because in relative
terms it is it's a mini version of the
m61 vulcan cannon firing 7.62 ammunition
rather than the much larger 20
millimeter caliber rounds another
connected term you might have heard is
gatling gun and it's with this 19th
century firearm the ideas leading to
today's fearsome minigun started to gain
traction but before we delve into the
invention of richard jordan gatling we
must go even further back into history
to the 14th century
it is here where we see the birth of
multi-barrel firearms in 1339 edward iii
of england fielded the first known
multi-barrelled firearm against france
during the hundred years war this
invention was called the rebaldaquin
also known as an infernal machine or
organ gun this piece of siege
engineering was made up of smaller
cannons laid side by side on a flat
horizontal platform with the idea of
firing a widespread volley of shot
across the battlefield it was expensive
took forever to reload and wasn't nearly
as popular as traditional canon during
the adoption of gunpowder but the idea
did spark an interest in volley guns or
multi-barrelled firearms that would
emerge again and again throughout
history albeit with mixed success with
firearms like the impractical puckle gun
of the 1700s the flintlock handheld
knock gun of the british navy or the
belgian mitch reluce of the 19th century
the idea of rapid-fire weaponry or
multi-barrelled guns was a concept
weapon designers kept revisiting but
would not find success in until richard
jordan gatling's most famous invention
the original gatling gun was invented in
1861 it was operated by a hand crank
mechanism that revolved at six barrels
around a central shaft with barrels
being fed a single cartridge from a top
mounted magazine and firing once per
full rotation this design meant that the
weapon could be fired at a much higher
rate and the cycling of the barrels
meant that they would not overheat
quickly ensuring continued fire
interestingly gatling believed that
inventing this weapon was a humanitarian
act rather than one of destruction he
had briefly practiced medicine during
his life and during the civil war had
frequently visited the trains bringing
in the deceased and wounded troops from
army camps and battlefields he learned
that only 3 out of 18 soldiers were
dying of their bullet wounds but the
rest passing away due to fever pneumonia
or other illnesses contracted at
military camps he devised that if there
was a weapon that fired more bullets
then fewer men would be required to
fight wars and resultantly there would
be less men to contract illnesses or
battlefield wounds and injuries there
was also the hope that such a fearsome
weapon would tend to discourage war
altogether julia keller author of mr
gatling's terrible marvel said he truly
thought it would end up shortening war
or perhaps even eliminating it
despite developments by the turning of
the century the gatling guns started to
be replaced in service by new weapons
utilizing advancements in gas and recall
operation namely hiram steven maxim's
maxim gun with this the idea of a weapon
utilizing rotating barrels largely fell
into disuse that was until after world
war ii where the united states military
started to consider new potential
weapons to be mounted on their aircraft
for this purpose general electric would
develop the m61 vulcan 20 millimeter
aircraft cannon capable of firing 100
rounds per second while utilizing its
six spinning barrels and from the vulcan
the minigun was born developed during
the vietnam war to mount on the side of
helicopters it was an alternative to
single barreled machine guns which were
prone to jamming or overheating the
smaller size also allowed for mounting
on ground vehicles and the smaller
caliber allowed for larger ammunition
reserves the m134 and its variants are
still in wide use being fielded by over
40 nations armed forces to this day it's
surprising how similar that thing is the
1862 gun designed by richard gatling a
cluster of rotating barrels which gives
you
a higher rate of fire and cooling both
of which are very important and spinning
with the barrels is is this cluster of
breeches as well breech block mechanisms
and a cam and it allows the one bolt to
be forward and firing as the next one is
fired and is extracting and each bolt is
doing a different bit of the process as
it goes around i mentioned this because
that's exactly how the vulcan works and
therefore that's exactly how the minigun
works the key difference there is
electrical power so the vulcan powered
by the aircraft's on-board
electrical system quite a powerful one
for obvious reasons the mini gun powered
by a large battery there was a gatling
gun on a u.s navy ship experimentally
electrically powered and i believe it
was 1890 so none of this technology is
new and it's over 100 years old but
there's nothing better for very for
basically putting up a curtain of lead
whether that's defeating an incoming
missile
or trying to kill an extraterrestrial uh
predator
in the jungle
clutched in the arms of bill duke
churning up greenery and undergrowth
while trying to hit a cloaked alien
hunter this scene from predator may be
one of the most iconic scenes in action
movie history and is certainly one of
the most recognizable shots from the
minigun's time on the silver screen but
i'm sure you'll be absolutely shocked to
learn that its depiction in predator
isn't exactly
realistic many larger-than-life action
blockbusters have used this popular
trope of our muscular hero slinging
curtains of lead towards their foes with
a handheld minigun from dwayne johnson
and furious 7 through to arnold
schwarzenegger in terminator 2 but
weighing in over 40 kilograms not
including the power systems and
ammunition using a minigun handheld
doesn't seem all that feasible at least
not for your average joe all in all
according to some rough calculations if
you take the gun itself a battery to
power the thing and enough ammunition to
keep it firing for just a single minute
you're looking at at least
200 kilograms that is
1.88 dwayne the rock johnsons
this thing is simply not meant to be
held and even if you are as ripped as
arnold schwarzenegger or terry crews
there's a factor aside from weight to
consider immense recoil
as a huge fan of things like predator
and terminator 2 i have often wondered
whether it might be at all practical to
actually fire a minigun from the hip or
whatever some people have said that the
guns used in those films aren't real
guns well they are they really are
holding those things they're bearing the
tremendous weight and bulk and they're
doing that side of the job but what
they're firing is blank rounds once you
factor in recoil of actual projectiles
to these things and 5000 rounds per
minute i think you can just intuitively
realize that there's no way you could
actually use this thing practically
having said that
a couple of people have tried
under
safe conditions because of the very high
rate of fire you can get maybe a handful
of rounds vaguely on target before the
thing just spins you off to the side the
rotating barrels the cumulative recoil
the fact that you have to hold it off to
one side you're just going to start to
spin around so you can't control the
thing for more than very very short
bursts which kind of negates the point
of using it in the first place if
striding around with a minigun in your
hands is out of the question you'd never
know it from pop culture it's a total
spectacle weapon a way to create
absolute carnage and destruction on
screen we see it mounted on helicopters
across dozens of military movies like
apocalypse now or rambo and in
blockbuster action movies like die
another day where the minigun is mounted
onto the back of the bad guy's jag it
even appears in many comic book films
too featuring on the batmobile and the
1989 batman over war machines shoulder
in iron man 2 or peppering cap's shield
in captain america the winter soldier to
name just a few and of course who could
forget its iconic depiction in the
matrix complete with reigning steel
links and brass casings
beautiful
so with all the action and impact that
the minigun carries it's unsurprising
that it's a common firearm that video
game developers have wanted to recreate
i'm sure we could all recall an
over-the-top set piece or a minigun has
been used to dial up the action or an
on-rail section of our favorite shooter
where we've been strapped into a vehicle
and placed behind a set of spinning
barrels with near infinite ammunition
but there are also games that lean a
little more into the spectrum of realism
allowing miniguns to exist in a manner
more befitting their role like rising
storm 2 vietnam's helicopter gunships or
in the vehicle mounted miniguns across
the battlefield series its earliest
appearance however was back in 1992
where wolfenstein 3d first puts half a
dozen spinning barrels into the hands of
its players
while the graphics are simplistic by
today's standard this weapon was without
doubt tapping into the spectacle of the
minigun although in game it was
erroneously named the chain gun a name
which refers to a single barrel machine
gun driven by a chain system this
misnomer was later adopted for all
similar weapons in doom and has stuck
from the 1993 original all the way up to
2020's doom eternal since its early 90's
appearance the minigun and its cousins
have cropped up everywhere supplied by
the liandry mining corporation to
tournament competitors or even in the
hands of a trio of plucky los santos
criminals wherever it crops up one thing
is almost always guaranteed a sack full
of ammunition and a plethora of enemies
to point out i think the minigun is
probably one of the least well
represented weapons in gaming and it
isn't just from
the unrealism of like ripping it off a
vehicle mount and just immediately
walking off to carry it more than that
it's how the guns are actually depicted
it's quite rare that they're shown to
function in the way that they actually
function
they're usually heavily heavily gamified
so the spool up spool down thing is
leveraged to
sort of limit how powerful the gun is so
you have to get it up to firing speed
whereas the way the thing really works
is yes it will spin without firing but
it spins at that consistent rate it
doesn't spin up to a high rate of fire
and then stay there and then drop back
down again they really step over the
line into into fantasy territory for the
most part if they're vaguely
realistically depicted it's because it's
a fixed section of a campaign or maybe
it's a mounted gun in a multiplayer map
and you are taking it over you're on the
door gun of a huey or something and
you're using it in situ we can then
start to see realistic depictions of
miniguns but then in my experience
playing playing certain games that allow
you to do that you don't really get the
sense of how devastating this thing
would be in real life because it's
incredibly hard to hit nothing with it
and the bullets don't have enough damage
overall maybe one of the less well done
guns in games but sometimes one of the
fun one of the most fun as well it's
rare that we see the minigun in movies
or games portrayed in a way that is
closer to reality than fiction but in
the case of a weapon that's larger than
life using a minigun is a virtual power
fantasy it's a tool used to inject a
heavy dose of action and an opportunity
for the players to let loose and wreak
some carnage when it comes to opening up
exciting moments for players or creating
memorable moments in movies does it
really matter that the pop culture of
the minigun is far from feasible do we
truly care that it would take a hulking
human being to carry as you may know i
am usually a sucker for firearms realism
in games but for the minigun it's a case
of fact versus fun and considering the
six spinning roaring barrels firing for
the side of fun i think we can all agree
to allow ourselves some enjoyment with
our virtual miniguns
thank you so much for watching this
week's episode of loadout if you enjoyed
it make sure you subscribe and like the
video and let me know either in the
comments section down below or on
twitter at a regular dave what else
you'd like to see a future episode on if
you want more video game weaponry
content you can watch the previous
series of this show or check out our
weekly series of expert reacts where i
show our friends at the royal armouries
a selection of video game firearms to
break down until next time i've been
your host dave dewitt thank you so much
for watching and i'll see you next time
you